hey guys welcome back to the
ever-charming theme park somewhere in
the middle of germany where today is
something newest edits at least I
haven't really seen it before and that's
why I wanted to try it a car ride which
you know just one of those very simple
rides in theme parks that just consists
of one simple rail with a bit of
concrete underneath it with either
antique cars or horses or that kind of
stuff running over it and it's not the
most interesting thing but I haven't
seen anybody do it in Planet coastal yet
and aside from that it's an attraction
which I've been planning in this park
for quite a while I think it fits quite
nicely into it since it is inspired well
not very loosely but just a little bit
too much perhaps by trips trail which is
absolutely riddled with these kinds of
rides and it's just a nice little family
ride or a it's a kiddie ride
Who am I kidding just a good addition to
the park it felt anyway it's something
that I was planning to have a bit of
interaction with a coaster with and fill
some of the area underneath the coaster
as well as some other parts of the
scenery which I'll get into in this
video as well but those won't be
finished in this video they won't be
finished in the next video I do it'll
probably still take about three or four
videos actually finish this entire area
and I'll also wait until that time to
like completely show it off this video
doesn't have any real time sections in
it next video will have about like a
five minute section of a small overview
in it but I'll only really start to show
the entire area a couple of episodes in
business is going to be quite a
time-consuming thing there will be a lot
of detailing involved in this park in
general much more than any of the parks
that I've made so far so you'll see that
pulse by sometime soon
anyway back to the topic of this little
ride
I wanted to start off with the station
which is maybe a little bit unusual
given that the layout itself is the one
thing that I didn't actually plan
beforehand since I wasn't really sure
how large the pieces would be and what
exact kind of curves I could make out of
the pieces that I would make the track
with so the station seemed like a very
good sort of anchor points to get in
first
make sure to actually have enough space
for it and be sure to have it the way
that I'm more or less wanted it to be
it's quite a simple station it's not
really to any sort of style just a
general style that hopefully should fit
in with the rest of the park quite well
and for these rides
you don't really too often see any like
particular queues or great organization
on the station's parts just a part of
the ride when you enter and leave it but
you know not too many people are going
to write these things anyway so you
don't really have to care about it that
much now what is quite interesting about
this though is the trick itself actually
made a couple of like prototypes of this
version since I really wasn't sure what
I wanted to make the trek out of and I
made a few out of the varying lights
concrete's materials that are in planet
coaster at the moment but they really
felt like they were too lights way too
bright and really didn't look good if
you kind of zoomed out and felt very
much out of place and really felt that I
couldn't really tie those in with the
more natural sort of relaxing charming
environments of this theme park with the
foliage and the scenery and all that so
I ended up going with the back side of
one of the doors to get a somewhat
darker though probably a little bit too
dark sort of concrete texture into the
concrete base and the windows quite
obviously just worked pretty well to get
that metal railing to
have the guys go over in the middle of
the track and I'm quite happy with how
that turned out in the end I'm not 100%
sure why I have that part on the side
sticking out there my original plan was
to have a a small section which is just
beside the track of concrete which
people can walk over because with rice
like these you often have like a bunch
of the vehicles that are all just you
know standing about in the station and
they'll just form this long train of
vehicles and you need to be able to at
least walk on the side of that's to get
to the one car that you want to get into
so wanted to get some space into that
and thought it would be great to have
that part sort of run into the track
over there to basically signal that
that's the point up to which people
actually walk up to the car that they
want to get into but in the end I'm not
really sure about that so I may very
well remove that at some point in the
future
now these curves were a little bit
tricky since the door is obviously quite
a big object and I wasn't really sure
like how tight I could make the curves
with this and my original plan was to
just place every single object
separately but in the end it turned out
to be a much easier efficient and also
better in terms of getting very tight
curves in approach to just make like
separate pieces so just like a curved
piece and a straight piece and that's
basically how this entire thing is being
made just stringing together those
pieces quite freely from the grid just
making sure that they're always quite
compact because I do want to keep it
quite tight on the space since this is
quite a small theme park yet at the same
time make sure that there is just enough
space between the tracks to be able to
fit flowers and that kind of stuff
between the tracks which is also why
this little section that I had at first
here isn't going to end up being what I
want to go with in the end since there
really is barely any space between the
tracks here other things that are
interesting about the ride is that it's
obviously a car ride
I do have some sort of car that actually
rides on top of it but as of yet I have
no idea what I'm actually gonna make for
its same goes for the monorail and it's
been that way for quite a while and the
only reason why I haven't done it yet is
because I'm really not sure how I'm even
going to tackle that and how I can even
make something realistic to place on top
of these things because I don't to make
something that is you know almost kind
of very similar-looking to what it
should be supposed to be but you know
something that where you can still tell
that it's trying to be a vintage car or
regret it's trying to be a truck but it
chooses look good because that's just
very you know taking you out of the
immersion I'm trying to make these rides
look at least as realistic as I can and
for that reason there are some parts
that I just want to leave out and that
just might not even be possible to do
realistically at all and I'm a little
bit afraid that the that the cars that
should sit on top of this are a part of
that but on the other hand there is
quite a bit of freedom and what kind of
vehicle you put on top of these right
since there are like endless variations
of these things so it all just depends
on a couple of tests of what can
actually work and just go with whatever
looks most realistic in the end might
not look the greatest and might not be
the best kind of ride but I at least
hope it's gonna be so more believable
overwrite and who's not really sure yet
if I'm actually gonna be able to do that
it's a quite a gamble over here same
goes for the monorail that's a pretty
sort of tough territory to get into as
well though I have seen some people make
some amazing rides out of scenery pieces
rides that don't even exist in the can
yet one thing that I definitely want to
talk about just because it's so amazing
is that at 30 V at the moment is making
a rapid ride out of the scenery pieces
and it's really ridiculous he's making
the rafts out of barrels using the
driftwood to make all sorts of parts of
the ride of the lift so on the station
and using
the driftwood actually to make like the
bottom parts of the rapids where you
have these wooden constructions that
bring up the waves of the of the ride
and you can really make some really cool
and creative stuff out of the elements
in the game and I think that's a really
great example of it
see y'all definitely check that out if
you're into that kind of stuff now
moving back on topic I wanted to you
have like a very small Plaza in the
middle of this little helix here since
well it's it was an open helix and I
wanted to make sure that every little
nook and cranny of this park is actually
used since it's quite a small park and
it seemed like a nice little place for a
small plaza in the middle of a helix
very similar to I believe the mine train
in Alton Towers as that kind of thing as
well might be mixing stuff up here but I
believe it does and yeah it seemed like
a nice place to have some benches some
place to sit down and watch the coasters
it passes by and get some X for a filled
space into that there now this other
space over here which is another little
space where I was not sure for quite a
while what to do with it is gonna be a
bit of like scenery sets piece I think
it's pronounced a trough or trot in
English but uh it's not my I'm not the
best at English but um basically it's
one of those drinking things for animals
and it just seems like a nice thing to
add theme-wise
because it's a thing that you see quite
a lot sand the Alps and just in general
in the southern parts of Germany I do
imagine you see them quite a bit along
hiking routes and around farms so I
wanted to get that in as a little piece
of scenery it doesn't really have any
kind of function beside being a piece of
scenery though it could very well also
just be a little fountain beside the
path where you can no fill your water
bottles or whatever you want to do or if
it's a very hot day just kind of wash
your hands in it whatever you want to do
with
a little fountain beside the pond it's
just a nice little touch that you can
add that has a bit of like themed pokey
and touch to it especially if you
compare it to parks like trip stream
which have quite a lot of these these
little more traditional kind of
decorations around the park and likewise
I bought it again quite a bit of foliage
in on the on the side of this and
underneath the monorail and the track of
the coaster which might be overdoing
things quite a bit again though you'll
probably see me overdo the foliage a lot
in the duration of all of these videos
since I just couldn't stop spamming
those amazing flowers maybe I do want to
start doing that a little bit less thing
is just with a point like this which
isn't that's big I do feel somewhat safe
placing more flowers and these flowers
aren't so much really flower bed flowers
but probably just flowers which don't
need as much care they're quite large
and they're not really arranged in any
sort of flower bed sort of patterns that
you see and like the larger very large
arranged flower beds you'd see around
Disney parks for example so I feel
somewhat safe at least getting all of
these little flowers as scenery around
the rides but yeah even with that many
flowers basically have around every
little nook and cranny of the ride I
still wasn't really satisfied and the
paths are still looking a little bit
whoa empty and bare and there's like a
border between two different parts that
are basically connected here just to get
a different path shape and a different
part path with that you can't really get
in game so hopefully people aren't going
to walk over that though I have had
guests actually walk over those gaps
between parts in the past but it seemed
like a very good place for some flower
boxes which I don't believe I've had in
a Polock so far but which I do want to
use quite a bit more because paths that
are just completely open without any
flower boxes on them or something that
you'd be you do see in theme parks
sometimes but I do want to make this
you know quite a bit more filled with
foliage and flower boxes are just a
really good way to get that extra charm
that [ __ ] and that extra you know
natural feeling to the paths and helps
to make them not look so empty I like
large stretches or nothing
no it quickly becomes like really open
and boring these new complex any trees
on top of parts and you can place any
bushes and flower boxes are just a a
nice little way to get rid of that now
the rest of this video is basically just
more and more flowers bushes and rock
work which is more or less the same of
what have already done and it's heavily
inspired by the rice at trips ville
which also have all of these
arrangements of bushes and flowers
around them as well
and one little touch that I am quite
happy with in the end Hanna made quite a
difference as small as it touches it may
seem is that leaves very little hills
between all of the dried tracks there of
course very small hills nothing natural
just hills that you could you know kind
of just scoop up with a bit of extra
soil but it's a nice way to get like
those slights hide differences and make
the trek honest seem to go through a
little valley and it just helps to make
all the bushes a little bit more visible
as well with no which is sitting high
and not blocking of the view of the
bushes behind them because you know it's
it's more like small hills of flowers
and decorations on the side of the
tracks and yeah that just helps to make
it look a bit more interesting than just
one big Flats area out with a lot of
foliage which would probably quickly
become quite boring not to mention that
many of these shrubs are quite low and
even though they do look fancy from a
top-down view if the ground would be
completely flat they don't really block
any of the view and you know it might
very quickly become this very large
stretch of just random bushes and I
didn't want to have that I wanted this
ride to feel more
you're going through the minimum of a
forest and the hills just kind of helped
to make the rest of the track a bit more
invisible make it feel a little bit more
close and like you're actually in a
densely packed forest even though I
couldn't really fit too many trees in
here because well the the right tracks
are very close to each other and as you
can see there are barely any open spots
where I could still fit some trees in so
hopefully these hills at least alleviate
that's a little bit and bring out the
bushes a bit more now the rest of this
video is basically just more of the same
and placing all this stuff around the
ride and the same is going to go for
well quite a few parts of the upcoming
videos which might be a little bit
boring so I want to take a bit of time
just to give some tips I might not be
the best at this stuff but I've
definitely picked up a lot of tips
through all the rct3 years one of the
things like one of the big mistakes that
you see quite a lot that you want to try
to avoid which I almost make over here
but it's a bad about fine because they
are belly and it's reason here is to
place a lot of crunch shrubbery and have
all of these flowers and bushes and then
place the trees over them while I would
recommend to start with the lower
shrubbery first before you get into
large trees you don't want to place your
trees over your flowerbeds because your
flowers will need sunlight to grow so if
you have a really dense forest trying to
avoid having as many flowers as you can
it's usually best if you actually do
have a dense forest going on or a big
line of trees alongside a path to have
like the flowers and the smaller shrubs
on the side of those trees and keep the
ground underneath the trees just empty
and grassy or whatever you want a riddle
on that ground that doesn't really need
any sun lights and in the end it doesn't
really matter that much either because
the ring of bushes will basically block
out the view of the grasses that's
behind it and with like bushes in the
Front's and trees in the back you can
usually provide a pretty good tree line
which makes anything that's beyond it's
quite invisible so that's something that
works quite often reason why I didn't
want to do
that kind of thing over here is
obviously that this is just and a good
bunch of crumb shrubbery with a few
trees in the mix just to make it look
it's a bit more foresty and a little bit
less open otherwise though I have to say
very honestly that's this is all just
winging it and I was in that cause and
talking with people I was barely even
paying attention while I was doing all
of this it's just random spamming of
random bushes at this points which I
guess worked in the end but it doesn't
always work if you really try to arrange
something in a certain pattern it's
probably best to pay a list of a little
bit of attention to it anyway that is it
for this time lapse so thank you guys
for watching and I hope to see you guys
next time in which I'll actually show
off this area in real time for a little
bit